so now we're moving on to weed
management and uh this is going to be um
uh uh dr rich bonanno from umass is
going to be leading our conversation
around weed management challenges
can everybody hear me okay
yeah okay thanks okay okay arnold can
you hear us we can hear you
okay
so we'll get right into it we'll waste
time since we're already behind uh if i
can figure out how to change the slide
i'll be there we go so i want to start
with some some sort of chronologically
start talking about perennial weed
control which is something that we're
going to be doing in the fall
i know some people have said well if i'm
going to be using roundup in the spring
to kill the cover crop isn't that also a
good time to go after a perennial wheat
and that's not the right time to go
after a perennial weed the perennial
weed needs to be controlled in the fall
because if you're after a perennial
you're looking to control
what's below ground almost more
important than controlling what's above
ground and the time you're going to get
the translocation of the roundup is
going to be in the fall and it's not
going to be in the spring so in terms of
fall timings
the
late summer or fall is the best time to
control the perennial weeds with roundup
or 24d
the thing is is that if it's a grass you
can go later
if it's a broad leaf you need to go
earlier before it gets too cold but
we're not just talking about perennials
now we're talking about the potential of
also having a cover crop there so you've
got to think of both of them being there
at the same time so if you're using
roundup you need to make the
applications as late as possible but
before establishing the cover crop you
do have the option of putting the
roundup on
after the cover crop is seeded but
before the cover crop comes up that can
buy you a few more days into the fall
because really later is better in most
cases once you get past
sort of mid-summer but again with the
broad leafs you don't want to wait too
long because if you get cold weather
you're going to hurt those broad leafs
you're not going to get the kill of the
perennials
so um but if you're using 240d if you're
after a broadleaf perennial and you're
establishing a grass cover crop you do
have the option of waiting a little bit
especially if you want to establish the
cover crop a little bit earlier because
as long as the cover crop has some
growth on it the 2 4 d will have minimal
effect on the cover crop and will still
control the broadleaf weed so if you're
after
something that's a vining weed
or
a dandelion or something like that 24d
can work just as well in the fall on
these broadleafs it's just that you've
got to get the grass a little bit
established first before you go ahead
and do it
okay
so now we get to the spring and we're
killing cover crops now and and i guess
i'm going to take advantage of having
some people in the room and just asking
a couple of a couple of questions what
rate of roundup are you using per acre
a quart and how many gallons of water
40. okay
all right so in general when you're
killing cover crops there's no question
that roundup is the most reliable
uh material that you can use
uh
keeping the things about roundup though
is that the more concentrated you can
make the droplets the better it's going
to work and i know there's been some
discussion back and forth about whether
or not you can do it in one application
or whether you need more than one
application there's there's some things
i maybe want to discuss that
might relate to how that all comes
together the first is that roundup will
always work better if you can put it in
less water per acre okay so 10 to 20
gallons of water per acre is better than
30 to 40 gallons of water per acre and
if if the cover crop is small and only a
few inches high i don't think it makes a
whole lot of difference but when you're
dealing with something that's a little
bit more vigorous and requires a little
bit more effort
using less water is better it's almost
counterintuitive because you think
you're not going to get enough coverage
but it really comes down to the
concentration of the droplets and so in
most cases you'll find that lowering the
amount of water is better now there's
two ways to lower the amount of water
one is
and let me just say that that reducing
the rate of water is a linear decrease
based on the type of nozzle you're using
so if you're using for example an o4
nozzle tip
and you're putting out say 40 gallons of
water per acre so if you're using an o4
and you're putting out 40 gallons if you
switch to an o2 you put out 20 gallons
if you switch to an 01 you put out 10 if
you have an o3 you put out 30. so it's
it's a linear kind of thing so to me the
simplest way to change the gallonage is
to change the nozzle tip that works a
whole lot better than driving twice as
fast or four times as fast because then
you're not going to do a good job you're
going to be bouncing the boom is going
to be flying so uh and because roundup
is a liquid it's it's a salt and it
dissolves basically in water you don't
have to worry about using a small nozzle
tip and having blockage like you might
be with a powder or something that they
could get stuck there
so really low using a smaller nozzle
tips really the better way to do it
conversely conversely and one other
thing is is uh just be careful about
your boom height you don't want to have
your boom so low that you're skipping
areas
or so high that you're maybe getting
excess drift so make sure you're getting
different decent coverage at least on
so the height of the canopy that's
giving you the most
foliage there so you're getting good
coverage
some people have asked about gramoxone
and gramoxone is a contact material but
most of these cover crops are annuals
and so uh getting penetration down to
the root system is not necessarily
something that we need the herbicide to
do uh the root system will die as a
result of the top dyeing uh so but the
difference is the gluoxon is a contact
material it's not a translocated
material so contacting every leaf is
much more critical and so ideally if you
can get the round the water levels up to
80 or 100 gallons of water per acre
you're going to do a lot better so if
you're normally using 40 and you were
going to try gramoxone you could just
drive half the speed you know as long as
you don't have to cover 100 acres or
something like that
as a way to um to change the gallonage
don't change pressure as a way to change
gallonage because that relationship is
not linear
you would need a 4x
change in pressure to give you a 2x
change
volume and you don't want to change the
pressure by 4x because you're going to
have fines flying all over the place
it's just not a good way to do it so
changing nozzle tips is much easier or
if you want to increase gallonage
slowing the tractor down is is a way to
do it and as many people have said
already uh wait until the cover crop is
dead capital dead before working the
soil sometimes and you know
my family will say dead or dead dead and
we're talking dead dead so make sure
it's they're really dead and the roots
are starting to decompose
before you try to work the soil
okay uh some questions that people have
asked this is what my slides are really
based on to try to cover some of these
things
so residue levels on herbicide
effectiveness uh and the first is that
all soil applied herbicides need to
reach the
re need to reach the soil and penetrate
the soil to work most of these
herbicides are working by either getting
into the root system as the radical
emerges from the weed seed or they're
designed to control the shoot of the
weed just as it's emerging from the soil
so you have to have the herbicide into
the soil and if rain is not imminent
then you have to irrigate just like you
would in any bare ground herbicide
application
now the thing that makes this a little
bit um
more difficult is
is it is it
is it difficult to get all this to
happen if you've got a heavy cover crop
there and certainly dead covers are
easier to work with i think that there's
less potential for uptake of the
herbicide into a cover
if the cover is dead if you've got green
foliage this seems to be always the
possibility that some of that herbicide
could be taken up by the foliage of the
weed depending on the herbicide so i
think dead covers are easy to work with
and as long as you've got enough
moisture to drive it through
then the amount of residue does not
affect the weed control because if it's
dead it's not going to be absorbing any
herbicide it's just a question of
getting it through that cover and and to
me that would be one of the biggest
questions uh that i would have in
general is just to make sure that you
get good activation because unless you
get that herbicide on the soil surface
it's just not gonna not gonna work or
actually into the top inch or so of soil
okay
uh cultivation a lot of people have
talked about cultivation and i guess it
really comes down to what crop you're
growing what kind of weed control you're
getting um
and and if you're really trying to
create a no-till environment or a
reduced tillage environment uh is is we
on a hillside is erosion important
on the other hand if you're not getting
good weed control do you need to really
get in there and and to be able to um uh
to knock some of those weeds back in
those row middles you know you may be
doing some cultivation right in the row
as well uh but to me as long as the
cultivator can be pulled through the
field and not clogged and the
cultivation is possible
i
i don't think though it's it's that easy
to do shallow cultivation one of the
things that always worries me about
cultivation is going too deep and
damaging the roots of the crop uh get
rid of losing excess soil moisture or
losing too much soil moisture and also
bringing more weed seeds close to the
soil surface so you're in effect killing
weed seeds but sort of repopulating the
top of the of the soil surface by
bringing more weed seeds back to the top
so and just remember that any surface
effects of residue cover are going to be
negated so if you have if you want that
cover there because of soil erosion
reduce soil splashing for diseases and
those kinds of things i mean you're
going to lose that when you go win and
cultivate but i realize that weed
control can be a problem here and and
for a lot of these crops
uh
you know sweet corn i'll discuss a
little bit later sweet corn is really
one of the best crops to grow because
you get excellent weed control but some
of these other crops you just don't have
the best weed control options to be able
to kill everything without throwing some
cultivation potentially into the mix
and this goes back to the amount of
cover i mean we saw that one shot there
where the cover was really really thick
and the person that commented on it
still talked about having problems with
weeds it can look really good to start
off with but it doesn't mean the weeds
will eventually come and it just depends
on the crop if you're growing pumpkins
you can get really good cover over the
top before the weeds come then maybe you
don't need cultivation but on the other
hand the soil is warm you don't have a
lot of cover the weeds are going to come
early
so
you know cultivation is something that
may be part of the mix and i already
already mentioned about shallow
cultivation it's always best but not may
not be the easiest when the cover
residue is present
with the right equipment i think it's a
little easier to cover in this
cultivating the strip where the crop is
growing
if you've got the right baskets if you
don't have stony ground maybe use a
basket cultivator uh i've even seen
people use
the small double front uh gangs like
from a little rolling cultivator they
get right in that bed right in the strip
it stays in there and then it minimizes
any any movement of soil outside that
strip so i think there's there's
possibilities uh i just think when
you're throwing the sort of the reduced
tillage aspect of it in the cover it
just makes cultivation more difficult
and that's more of an equipment issue uh
than anything else
uh soil types and and rates
uh basically uh and my second bullet
point has a problem with it that i i
realized this morning so let me i'll hit
that later but first bullet point so
soil types and rates follow the label
directions for the amount of herbicide
to use
just like you would normally do based on
soil organic matter and soil type so the
amount of residue on the top has nothing
to do with selecting the rate you can't
say oh geez i get all this cover there
so i must need the higher rate that goes
along with the higher organic matter
content because that's not the type of
organic matter you're worried about with
herbicides when you're talking about
organic matter and herbicides you're
talking about humic acid you're not
talking about raw organic matter sitting
on the surface so just
as you would with any rate you look at
that rate you look the percent organic
matter of your soil you look at your
soil type and that's how you select the
rate so in general less sand and more
clay requires a higher rate for most
herbicides also a greater amount of soil
organic matter not residue cover usually
requires higher rates so so rates are
the same regardless of whether cover is
there or not
soil type does not generally affect
the choice of herbicide i put rate here
but that's wrong what the question
really had to do with the selection of
the herbicide so soil type generally
does not affect the selection of a
herbicide unless you're talking about
either soils that are very very high in
organic matter like muck soils where
certain herbicides don't work and the
label will say they don't work or you're
dealing with soils that are very very
sandy and there might be issues with
with
either leaching or something with soils
certain labels may preclude an
application on certain soil types
because the organic matter is very very
low
but generally none of this should affect
the rate that you apply of any of these
materials
okay so i i wanted to just to go through
three different crops were mentioned to
me
and uh oops
i went the wrong way now my point is
doing all kinds of things
okay
can you get me back on track there
yeah and pop me down to uh the first
crop
crucifers okay it was interesting to me
that somebody asked a question about
crucifers because
um even though this is new for a lot of
people when i used to work at north
carolina state university
back in the 80s we actually had a
research project with the tennessee
valley authority and our issue back then
was up in the mountains of north
carolina eastern tennessee basically up
in appalachia
there were huge erosion problems and a
lot of cabbage growers guys growing
cabbage and broccoli on very very hilly
soils and we were looking at this whole
system back then for erosion control and
we were using something called the bush
hog
road till which was basically a strip
tillage piece of equipment had two
fluted cultists in the front it had the
subsoiling shank and it had the baskets
in the back and what we were doing is we
were going into covers exactly the same
as this killing the cover crop in the
spring but the crop in question was
cabbage cauliflower and broccoli and
pretty much a transplanted uh crop in
these soils
and so
what we found and this just sort of
highlights the sort of the importance of
herbicides here generally in this
country the move to reduce tillage and
no tillage sort of became more practical
and possible with more herbicides being
registered because of the whole
cultivation thing and and the ability um
uh to you know losing the ability to
cultivate in a lot of cases
so it was actually when we got goal
registered as a pre-transplant herbicide
did the whole system fall into place
because we just didn't have a good broad
leaf material so basically with
cruciferous we're talking about
transplants gold pre-transplant followed
by either devon or dakbal over the top
after transplanting our use of treflan
is difficult because it has to be
incorporated it only works in the strips
it's not going to use between work
between the strips without incorporation
so we never really were able to use
treflan in this in the system uh in some
cases and depending on the state and so
forth command could be used command's
only registered in cabbage though it
would be used not to replace the gold
but instead of either devernal or dakbal
and also in some states there's a
registration for dual a dual magnum uh
for controlling broadleaf or some
broadleaf weeds and grasses and
crucifers so again uh goal would be the
basic material pre-transplant followed
by any one of these grass herbicides but
also has some broadleaf activity so
either debranol or dakbal or depending
on the situation commander duel
of course in any of these crops if
grasses come through crabgrass panicums
foxtails and so forth any of the
post-emergence grass materials can be
used depending on what's registered so
post fuselate select ashore depending on
what the the label is
weed management i think with direct
seeding is difficult because you lose
the opportunity to have the goal uh
unless you're using the transplants and
so i think as you're going to other
crucifers other you know cruciferous
greens where you don't have the goal
option it makes it more difficult uh in
a direct seating application
so
this is something i actually have a lot
of experience with but but again
transplants and goals seem to be the key
uh to making this this work
okay
next one
so winter squash and pumpkins there was
a question on that uh this is a little
bit easier i think we've got some pretty
good materials registered for winter
squash and pumpkins uh but still
you've got to be careful about how all
this works uh there was a question about
transplants before and then direct
seeding and that's an issue here that
i'll talk about so basically um we're
talking about the same herbicides as you
would use in conventional tillage
systems which are our main stage really
involves strategy which is a pre-pack of
command and kerbet some people choose to
use those materials separate some people
choose only to use the kerbet part or
only this the command part but but
strategy is a very common material i
find that in some in some other states
it's not used as much because growers
consider it to be an expensive treatment
but for us
strategy and sandia are fairly common to
use
sandia has the potential to be used
either pre pre-emergence or
post-emergence the problem is is that
if lamb's quarters breaks through common
lamb's quarters and that's a really
tough weed to control once it breaks
through even though sandia might take
out for example pigweed post-emergence
or gallon sauger or a number of other
weeds post-emergence it will not take
out lamb's quarters post-emergence so if
you find that you don't
get good lambs quarters control with
strategy alone you've got to have the
sandia with the pre-emergence otherwise
if you get the lamb's quarters up you're
in some serious trouble
um
so but between the row there's a bunch
of options so for example if you were
looking to um
maybe use transplants and and minimize
what you put in the row
and you wanted to come in and do
something between the rows and you
didn't want to rototill you didn't want
to cultivate
between those rows or run a harrow or
something depending on how far apart
your pumpkin rolls your winter squash
rows are there are some herbicide
options for between the crop rows only
now of course sandia can be used either
over the row or between the rows but aim
which is a burn down material gramoxon
which is a burn down material and any of
the post-emergence grass materials can
be used between the rows of pumpkins and
winter squash the label requires that
either aim or gramoxone be be shielded
but the post-emergence grass herbicides
can be used with without a shield
okay and i think we've got one more here
and that's sweet corn and i would say
that perhaps the easiest crop to grow
from a weed control standpoint is sweet
corn just because there's so many
options available you've got great
pre-emergence options
and you've got excellent post-emergence
options i mean if you're growing any
corn i mean if you're growing field corn
you've certainly got roundup ready as an
option to be able to come up with
roundup but the thing is for sweetcorn
we don't have that option we still have
a number of options available a lot of
people are coming in with with bicep
early
or bicep with some callisto added to it
or
just dual or lasso was a grass material
along with callisto and a low rate of
atrazine one of the things that
callisto's done for us is allow our
atrazine rates to get pretty low a
quarter of a pound in some cases if
you're going to use the callisto as well
you don't have any really bad weed
problems
any of the grass materials like dual or
lasso and then post emergents just a
number of options you come in with now
that are in the new york and the
mid-atlantic and the new england guides
for post-emergence options for weed
control that will control a lot of
broadleaf weeds and and now um uh some
better grass activity with some of these
post-emergency materials uh so i i think
we've got a great job uh potential to do
it with without cultivation i think with
a lot of the other um crops
that cultivation uh you know has its
place because you may not get great weed
control depending on what's there but
sweet corn you should be able to do the
best job and as you move away from these
crop groups here you move away from the
crucifers you move away from the
cucurbits you move away from sweet corn
weed control becomes increasingly
difficult just because you don't have
good materials available and then you
really got to start thinking about
cultivation and you know if your
objective is uh breaking the soil pan
and working on phytophthora you know
maybe having that residue on the surface
is not that important to you and and so
cultivation becomes more of something
that that's a practical uh thing to do
in addition to whatever herbicides that
you might apply
so with that i'll stop and i'll take any
questions at this time
thanks rich why don't we just start with
questions from your location first and
uh we can just do two from a site and
then we'll rotate around to the various
locations
anybody have any weed control questions
for rich
okay so one question was tomatoes
actually tomatoes are not a bad crop to
work with either because you've got
cenkor
to use it's a good broadleaf material uh
the weakness with uh sencore is going to
be uh
nightshade type weeds uh so within the
row that could be a problem uh this was
assuming we're not growing on plastic
now so this would be bare ground i think
that if you if you're going to use
plastic and i haven't heard much being
talked about this but it seems like if
you're going to use plastic you're going
to be sub soiling and then you're just
going to be working the entire soil
surface because i don't see how
practical it is to lay plastic with a
lot of cover there
so
but i think cencor makes it a little
more practical because you've got some
good materials there
anything else here
okay adam
um okay how about we go to western new
york
i have a question um
did i hear you correctly you said aim is
abused for burndown for lamb's quarters
and pumpkins and squash
only between the rows though and i'm
looking at um if i grab the label i
believe it's winter squash and pumpkins
for the aim label uh you may want to
just verify that but that is a between
row only and it has to be shielded
okay um
you can't use it on summersquash then
correct
okay
any other questions from western new
york
there are quite a few herbicide options
in beans
so that that's one that uh can be
handled pretty well
i agree i agree with you we didn't
mention that but there are a lot of
options uh you've actually got better
options in new york than we have in new
england because of reflex label uh
and and i know robin belinder has done a
lot of work with that so i would agree
that
snap beans and
some of the dry beans have some great
options as well
any other questions folks
okay for new york
okay um uh long island
yeah we have a question
uh yes i've i've been experimenting with
zone till sweet corn for the last two
years
and i haven't been able to maintain
appropriate weed control
we don't have the use of lasso or dual
and so i've been using primarily
atrazine and prowl
and or
callisto and i was wondering if you
could comment on
uh what you think the
best materials
or the best program might be
all right
could you guys turn the powerpoint off
at your location
maybe i did i'm sorry
um
okay
uh certainly we have we have a similar
problem on some of our soils there are
zone two soils where uh certain
herbicides are not allowed to be used
uh prowl and
you know prowl is not a bad material
combined with the broadleaf materials it
depends it let me just if i ask you a
question back what's what's the worst
problem you're having with those choices
that you're you've indicated
in terms of
generally grasses
okay
uh so i i guess one of the things i
would question would be the rate of the
rate of prowl to make sure you're using
the right rate
to get to get that control
uh the other thing is that
so you can't use any of the incorporated
materials they're just not going to work
well in this situation uh and when you
take the dual and the lasso world so
really prowlers is your your main option
there but make sure you're using the
right rate to at least get the right
residual control uh to start off with
also remember that uh prowl is a type of
material that is taken up by the roots
of weeds it has no effect sitting on the
soil surface it has no effect sitting
close to the soil surface because
there's no shoot uptake the way prowl is
going to kill these weeds is by
inhibiting cell division in the roots as
the roots are coming out from below the
weed seed so incorporation is critical
the other thing uh in sweetcoin now is
that we do have um
is it accent
uh that it's been registered recently
and that is a post-emergence grass
herbicide that's actually got very good
tolerance and a lot of varieties of
sweet corn so it may be something you
want to think about
and uh then
some of the callisto-like products
that have been out there
have also
have some potential
for
post-emergence grass control
they're not as good as using the right
rate of prowl at the beginning
uh if that will work for you they're not
as good as
the accent that i just mentioned
but they do have uh let me just real
quick i'll just give you a couple of
names of those
how would you incorporate the prowl if
you're not well you don't have to you
have to irrigate it prowl is not like
treflan it does have some water
solubility associated with it uh so you
can't irrigate it you can't get it and i
believe on sweet corn you do not you're
not allowed to incorporate it even if
you're on a bare ground situation so
it's it's a it's a
it's an application that's made uh
uh by putting water in the other thing
to keep in mind and this is something i
haven't said a whole lot about but soils
are generally going to be colder in this
whole environment that it's a plus in
the road middles because it delays the
weeds coming up
but it also can be an issue right in the
strip so one of our concerns about prowl
on sweet corn is unusually cold soils
and so i'm always nervous about the
first couple of plantings of sweet corn
in cold soils
we tend to not use prowl as much and to
use it on warmer soils so that's just a
little issue with prowl that i'm not
really sure how you get around but some
of these post-emergence materials that
are callisto like include loudest and
impact and both of them have some
post-emergence grass activity
the accent material accent q
is is primarily a grass material that
also works well but it only works on
grasses so i think from if you're not
getting good activity out of prowl you
do at least have some additional post
emergence options in corn that don't
require drop nozzles and those are the
ones that i just mentioned accent q uh
impact and also loudest
callisto probably has the the worst
grass activity of that group but it's
not bad on small crabgrass
anything else
we had one more question
um with the use of strategy and sandia
in the pumpkins um
a pre-emergent
and with a bunch of residue i know on
the labels it requires about a quarter
of an inch or so of rain to get it into
the soil with a good amount of residue
do you suggest more and how much if we
had to irrigate
i i agree that you need more
how much more really is really going to
depend on the residue but you may be
half an inch is not impractical
to get it through
it should move pretty well through dead
plant material
so i don't think you need an inch
but the other thing i failed to mention
when i was talking about pumpkins and
winter squash is that those labels you
cannot use that stuff over the top of
transplants when they're newly
transplanted and so sometimes if you're
in this situation maybe direct seeding
is the is the better option because your
herbicide options are definitely better
with direct seating versus transplanting
great all right how about
questions from here from ithaca do we
have any questions
no
all right um uh any final questions for
rich from any of the locations oh jeff
we didn't get to your site
no questions here he did a great job
thank you i know i actually i have a
question
is that okay yeah go ahead
all right and this has nothing to do
with weed control but i've been thinking
about this in the back of the room and i
and if i don't ask it i'm going to feel
bad because i'm going to leave to go to
another meeting so
soil again soils the ph is going to be
best near the surface where you're
working the soil as you go deeper uh how
does that ph change and when you pop
that that uh culture through the the
plow pan and you're thinking about roots
going down how well do those roots grow
as they go deeper into the soil and
especially if they're growing below the
plow pan and you're into soils that i
would
imagine are fairly low ph's down there
how does it all work or is water uptake
are you really getting out of that are
you not getting nutrients from that far
down i'm just curious about the deeper
soils and lower ph's as you go down
maybe i should have paid attention when
i was in college but but i don't know
the answer to that question
um uh i'll just take i i hit it and i
would open it up to anyone else that has
some experience in thinking about this
but as we when we have the salt we are
getting better foraging of roots deeper
in the soil
um
observed or red anything about issues
around the change in ph with the depth
of the soil profile because that the
roots are filling up that whole volume
of soil has been disturbed
and so the gen the improvement in the
root growth and the improved vigor of
the crop in its ability to forage has
been the benefits of doing this zone
tilt system
so i didn't know if there was any other
comments or observations from other
growers that have been doing this
rely on
yes go ahead
we've had several cases where we have
gone through the plow tanks and got down
into some ph of 5.1 or something
and it is absolute depth on corn they
may come up and grow to be six eight
inches tall water roots finally get down
to that
so deep tilling is can be death from a
crop if they get down into a ph that's
not appropriate for the crop that is you
want to grow
we had a tremendous example of this in
pennsylvania and new hampshire this year
and
basic agronomy 101. you can't grow it in
ph 5.0
so um
jim can you speak to what happened at
that point
phil the corn died
no no i mean no
good
did the grower quit using the system in
those fields
no he
he still wants to use the system but
he's not going to deep till until he
gets the ph changed in the whole soil
profile he's going to be putting his
nitrogen shallow and you know tillage
will only be 10 inches deep or 12 you
know with a strip till
so he's not messing around down in that
low ph stuff
um you're gonna be proactive with your
liming so that
you you keep putting it on if you're
gonna need it because it takes longer to
get down there
right
because
the ph you know you've got to use a
cornell ph kit to take a pinch of soil
from two feet deep or 17 inches deep or
whatever and see if it's you know
appropriate for the crop if it gets way
low then either you know kill and grow
shallow or
or something else grow something mills
we haven't talked about sampling soil
deep for ph doesn't take long and it's
cheap for a ph kit in your pocket you
know in a soil probe you can tell what
it is at two inches ten inches 20 inches
but we haven't talked about it we've
talked about with um
no-till doing shallow ph and regular phs
and on the muck because of
real low ph stuff
we're starting to do sampling um
below 12 inches
some look some bucks will have a ph of
seven too if they go down into the
calcium
layer that would
decayed too but it's something that we
need to consider as is
the ph testing
if
if you suspect something i guess
right ask the plan i don't have a
question for you
when you took the soil samples from the
field you guys trialed
this past season how deep did you go on
that because that field has been heavily
lined for years
um the only thing i did different was
the last three years it's been a super
heavy
cover crop on it that i've i've tried to
build the organic matter in that field
is that what drove that ph down so low
because that thing came back like five
nine or something
there's no way it should be really even
close to that
cornell test yeah
yeah i don't i think that we sampled
that soil fairly shallow for the soil
health test
i don't think that we did a full 12 inch
depth on that but we can do that again
this year
would heavy cover crop over extended
period of time cause that to be that low
on the surface
i wouldn't think so
this is jude in massachusetts
yeah i have a couple a little bit of
experience to share with you on this
um
generally with with reduced tillage you
want to pay strict attention to you to
your lyming practices you need to do it
more frequently um regularly um we had a
grower that has been using zone till for
a while and he was trying to zone till
one year and then leave his um he was
preparing beds and this was for bean
production preparing raised beds with
them to try to combat some disease
problems
and he was leaving these beds for three
four years
and over that time period his ph would
dive throughout the entire field
even though he would would topically
apply
lyme
on if not every year every other year
what we had him do was come back in and
rebuild those beds re-zone till every
single year to solve the problem
and that seems to have turned it turned
his plantings around
i think
you can run into some problems with this
for instance gary sweet out in ohio
does uh zone tilling in the same slots
every single year he well he zone tails
first and then he uses a a multivator
over the top so he's just
basically strip tilling over those same
zones and replanting in those areas and
before he came to new england to talk i
asked him i said are you having problems
with your with us acidification going on
in those slots because in new england
with our soils if you did that and
applied some nitrogen fertilizers in in
that slot year after year your your ph
would really dive in just a short period
of time i don't know what happens with
ohio soils maybe they have to suffer
their soils instead of lime them
so maybe he's getting away with it that
way he says he claims his crop's
improvement every single year but what i
suggested that he do was go back into
those slots and run some soil ph tests
both shallow and deeply uh and also
between the rows to see if he's having
problems with the ph starting to to dive
in those
slots
so there are considerations that growers
will have to think about when they get
into this type of things
i think with the with the deep zone till
as opposed to a no-till system you do
have the opportunity to move some lime
deep in the soil obviously it's not
throughout the entire
soil profile in the field it's only in
the slots that you're disturbing on
those particular years which again
reinforces the fact that you need to
apply the lime regularly
thank you jude
do we have other comments on sort of
liming strategies or what people have
been doing in their zone tillage
and their deep zone tillage
george or lynn
yeah yes we're in okay well
go ahead
with lime and reduced or no
tillage i think the use of the airway
tillage tool if you put spread lime on
the surface and then airway relatively
aggressively you know that
rainfall will move that lime into that
top six inches of the soil
fairly well
if we want to avoid
you know tillage and you know full
tillage
we've seen that be fairly effective
that particular field i knew that you
guys tested um that's the field i dumped
the line in um in the piles that we work
out of so that's always the first one to
get done everywhere that one's never
been skipped
and that's just been broadcast treated
with lime but
there's been years that was done like
three years in a row
um with high kale lime that's why when i
got that soil test on again this cannot
be right you know with all that lime
it's been applied to that thing
but i don't know i i just the only thing
i'd done different was it was three
years of continuous rye
i was trying to
just do a little testing and see if it
would help my phytophthora problem if i
planted nothing there but rye
so
some of the rye had never had the last
couple years i hadn't even taken their
eye off i just dissed it down let it
reseed so it came up really thick
that stuff was such a heavy heavy sod
this year i had to spray that with
roundup a long time because it was it
was
you know it's a lot thicker crop than
you normally plants way more than three
bushel per acre seed
so
i didn't know if that would have caused
it or not but there was
i it was really nice um
loamy soil when i worked it up this year
i mean it i think i i don't know what i
did as far as organic matter i was kind
of shocked that that didn't come up
either with the amount of biomass i put
down in it over a three year period
i don't know i'd make a comment about
the line
that jude was talking about one of the
things that we learned way or we were
told way 15 years or so ago when i
started was to move the deep the zone
builder strips every year in other words
the grain farmer grow will grow a 30
inch row and then the second year you're
still in the middle
and whether it's sweet corn or
vegetables or what move it over to the
side because i've been spreading lime
regularly but every year i till a little
different place i never go in the same
row and so in those colders on the back
of that tiller are telling three or four
inches deep to make that mound and so
you're working six to eight inches of
ground
to work the lime in every time you do it
and so if you move every year and don't
put your room in the same place over a
three or four year period you're going
to end up tilling the whole field and
that's making i'm not having a problem
with ph even though i zone till every i
use zone tillage every year i don't have
a problem with it getting lower and
lower ph because i could spread a ton of
lime every say once every three years
and then over that period of time i work
the whole field once and it makes it it
keeps working it in the soil so that's
the secret i think is not to put your
row on the same place every year there's
other reasons for terms of soil
compaction and other reason not to do it
but the liming is one of them
we have a question here on long island
about the lime if anybody might be able
to address it okay
i have a question in regard to the
effect that compost might have on the ph
in the soil
i
recently applied approximately 25 tons
of compost that
tested about seven and a half ph
and i'm not sure whether that would have
any
long-term or even short-term impact on
the soil ph i was wondering if anyone
could address that
i've not done any compost
um how
how many years have you been doing this
in a row
uh
two
two
um we we have done some work where we we
haven't used that high of a rate um but
in other work and other observations the
ph does tend to go up slightly
over time with heavy rates of complex
capacity
i have observed that but it depends on
the amount and
concentrated it looks on the field
25
of a material that
um
it can depending on what the source of
the material was and what the source of
the compost was um will have a different
effect
what the food stock was
grass and brush
okay
the other thing that you want to
consider with this is um
the
organic matter in in your soil existing
as was mentioned earlier there was a
problem up in new hampshire when they
were deep applying the the nitrogen
for sweet corn uh and what we determined
that problem to be was that the organic
matter levels were extremely low in
those soils it was a sandy
merrimack soil
and
basically it didn't have the buffering
capacity so when the when the um
all the nitrogen was applied all at once
um what was happening was the the ph in
that area was was crashing
over a point it was dropping from 6.2
down to 4.8 as low as 4.8
um other areas of the field didn't have
any problems
so so the more you put
that compost down
uh the more you're going to have
buffering capacity in your soil and you
shouldn't have problems with that type
of a ph drop a sudden ph drop and
basically that's the recommendation we
came up with for the grower in new
hampshire was to start adding some
organic matter to his soil so that he
could try to
get back to that
deep deeply applied
nitrogen
just a comment on jude
i believe that farmer in new hampshire
the ph down at 17 inches was 5.1 or so
am i wrong
i didn't do the sampling myself so i'm
not sure exactly if he did any any deep
deep sampling but
even on the surface in six inch deep
samples uh he had low low phs
i believe that phone call come out of
the blue at a meeting in pennsylvania
and
the i thought from the conversation that
the the crop grew to be six seven eight
inches tall and then the roots got down
into that nasty ph 5.0 and then that's
when they
headed south and died
is this a temporary ph crash um
because the the pumpkins i had planted
on this field where this ph was so low
were beautiful i mean it was just a mass
of green
everything was fine um
but i had broadcast 100 pounds of
nitrogen uh with my herbicide
i don't know is that possible that's
what caused that ph crash
well i can't answer that question i know
the pumpkins are a little more tolerant
to a low ph situation than the sweet
coins going to be that's one of the
questions we asked we answered for keith
uh during the questioning period
but i can't tell you uh exactly
what caused it
i believe that that
sweet corn in new hampshire that the
nitrogen was placed about seven inches
deep from the soil surface
so that too that was the constant you
know most really there's a rule of eight
the
nitrogen should be at least eight inches
from the seed if it's going to be below
it and i think that that nitrogen was
placed shallow with my conversation with
the grower and i wonder if that
didn't have play into this whole
there's mess possibility i guess i guess
you have to answer ask yourself how
critical the the last inches
right
at this point um we are into the section
of our
video conference where we were talking
about fertility and we've just moved
into that quite naturally um now one
thing that we've started to allude to is
the use of deep-placed nitrogen
in the slot and
i didn't know if there were some growers
online here that have been trying this
and would like to share some of their
experiences and what prop they've been
doing this with
uh we'll start in western new york and
i'm not sure uh enter georgia if you've
been using deep placed n or not
no i haven't done any deep placement
because i'm growing all my sweet corn
and pumpkins now following killed
alfalfa so i don't need the nitrogen so
uh
don branton is the only one that i've
had any experience with and i'd be doing
what he does if i needed the nitrogen
but i haven't needed any so at this
point i haven't done anything except put
the nitrogen on with the planter
i haven't either
i haven't tried it yet either it's
something uh i want to experiment with
and the tomatoes and things like that
but uh just not set up to do it and
haven't taken the time to build anything
to try to place it down there
i believe um
uh joe brightly and casey kuhns
did use some deep end
with uh squash and cabbage
this past year
and they saw really uh pretty good
results with both of those i believe
yeah
yeah
in in our own work we've been using
we've been looking and comparing the
basically a deep placed end with all of
the nitrogen applied at the beginning of
the season and comparing that to a sort
of more conventional program with side
dressing and we've seen no difference in
the performance just confirming the
observations that donnie has had and
other growers have had around the region
and doing this sort of placement
and this year we're probably going to
look at more closely using it with uh
brassicas with transplanted cabbage
and perhaps also with squash
i'm not sure if there's any growers in
west in western mass that are doing any
work with the deplaced end
um i don't think so you guys are both
using
right yeah
um
here
oh can we ask uh the growers there that
are doing some zone tell uh what the
crop is and what is their fertilizer
program or how they're going about it
yes um i'll hand you over to alan
zakowski first
i used it on cucurbits
and sweet corn and tobacco
and i apply banded fertilizer on the
cucurbits and sweet cornet planting time
and then i top dress just before they
run so most of my fertilizer is is close
to the surface
slightly worked in and i don't really
see a problem that we get a few rains
the nitrogen leeches down
to where it needs to be and i've had
really good yields
i'll hand it over to wally
we're basically doing exactly the same
thing we use liquid fertilizer band it
when we plant then we side dress with
the littlest and cultivator
and it's been working fine
um and that was we i think we have one
one other
okay
sounds like the same system all around
and that was all uh you said pumpkins uh
squash
yes and sweet corn
all right how about on long island i
know we have some growers on long island
that are um doing some zone tillage
would they care to share some of their
fertilizer approaches
i i'd like to reduce you using the slow
release fertilizer
we haven't tried the
deep placement of the nitrogen but um
the last two years i've been using a 65
esn nitrogen that we've been pretty
happy with
put down a planting
yeah
so that's applied at planting and what's
the crop
i've been using it on our sweet corn and
pumpkins
and i'm sorry i didn't hear the rate
i've
been following the recommends for the
respective crops okay
all right
um any other um
growers there that are doing some zone
till that would like to share what their
approach has been with the particular
crop
i knew we've always done we've put down
about um
i think it's about 60
10 10 10
in the soil next to the plant and then i
follow up later on in the season with
liquid nitrogen through the drip
irrigation system
we have worked with some
slow release fertilizers but we found
that our soils are cold so they don't
release quick enough so we need to
change that
so that there's more available in the
beginning of the season because they get
a slower start
okay uh anyone else from long island
i guess that's it
okay
um how about jeff i didn't know if any
of your growers are doing don't tell in
your area that would want to share some
of their approaches
uh the people that have done zone till
are not here at the meeting today so we
don't really have anything to add
related to that i did have a question
for you anu
first what do you call what do you
consider deep placement how many inches
down and then are you using any kind of
nitrogen stabilizer
uh i can just speak to what we've been
doing in our trials and then we can ask
i think that jim capron in western new
york well let me start with you jim
because i know that you've worked with
several growers doing different
configurations so why don't you start
i can't because i'm talking about things
i was just in the back of the room
talking about stabilizers and you know
my theory on nitrogen
uh is that we really where we're going
to be putting it all on you know at or
before planting with the ripper or the
stripper or the planter you know
ammonium thiosulfate liquid nitrogen
nitrogen with ammonium thiosulfate is a
very good way to go or you know guardian
or there's you know agretane and some
other you know inhibitors and so forth
and i think it
you know it's very very important that
we have this because the nitrogen is out
there hanging around for a long time
we can make it so it doesn't deny your
fire you know in a soggy soil situations
or
leach in the
lighter gravelly sandy soil situations i
think that's very important to keep our
nitrogen where we want it when we use
that you know i call them happy plants
the corn comes up green stays green and
never turns anything but dark green you
know for the whole growing season
including
you know sweet corn like we had down in
freeville and so forth
um
i think it's real important for this
nitrogen management scenario to have
some an inhibitor
with it and that works about six weeks
four weeks
i don't know
30 days or so
it's relatively short but you know in a
month's time or six weeks time we've got
the corn up to where it's going to begin
to take up nitrogen at a faster rate
so that anything that's leached a little
ways we can probably get at and you know
bring it back up with the roots of the
plants but you need some banded
fertilizer to get the plant through
until it gets down to the right
i think the old standard 2x2 fertilizer
there ought to be in a corn you feel
corn type situation and i don't think
that sweet corn is much different
needs
30 to 40 pounds in the fertilizer band
to get that corn to knee-high without
you know
its roots are a far greater shape than
at knee-high in order to you know get
any that deep place nitrogen or ban you
know to blend beside the zone tilt
coulters irregardless of tillage method
irregardless of tillage method the
fertility
deal is the same with conventional or
with zone till the nitrogen's got to be
in the soil where it ought to be
positioned correctly or it's not blended
throughout the whole
soil soil profile evenly everywhere and
what about inferior fertilizer
don't go too much you know in
fertilization you've got to be really
careful with
7 or 9 18 9 or something
you know a couple gallons you can
i'll go along with that 10 gallons i'm
against because you're proud you've run
the risk of a stand
establishment problem with the seed and
the tender little seedlings but you
can't get enough bond like you would
with a starter then
right
nitrogen right
you know too much nitrogen plus potash
is where we get into trouble especially
if we put fertilizer in the seed furrow
you know
under five gallons of acres you can
twist my arms a point any anything over
three i'm i'm nervous
so um as far as when we've been using
the deep placed in uh we've been going
about eight inches below the seed i
don't know if any growers have gone any
shallower when they're doing some
transplants i think john altabelly was
going six inches below when he was
transplanting
cauliflower
as far as his placement of
nitrogen that's in how were his results
excellent he had a really great crop he
was very impressed with the performance
so is it is it better to say stay at
like six inches versus ten for most
crops or
well i guess um six to eight i think
eight inches is a good one it's a safe
place to be
and again that would depend on your soil
type
i don't 10 inch is always just
any deep place then in long island
i'm sorry about that invited me to cut
you off she couldn't yeah no
i wouldn't say deep places
yep
in long island i don't believe there's
anyone there that's been doing it um uh
any trials because of their stands and
other issues